crack on perhaps i can just ask the
members if there are any declarations of
interest they may wish to register no
thank you chair i would like um the
everybody to know my members interests
and also i was previously the maritime
minister as well
i'd like great
committee to know that i'm a former
member of the rmt union
uh thanks chad i'm a member of the rmt
parliamentary group and uh for a number
of years i've known mick lynch and i did
have meetings on monday
with um some of the sat in victimized
seafarers and with from the rmt and with
um
nautilus international
uh actually as did i so i should also
raise that uh interest i was there with
you at the time graeme
and uh yeah i'm also declaring my
membership of the rmt parliamentary
group and again i've had meetings with
uh norton assange with rmt over this
issue
excellent okay i think we've all
remembered that we've been meeting with
the rmt on that basis right okay for
reasons known to my clerk i need to swap
the chair over to uh darren jones he's
going to take us through the first four
panels darren
thank you hugh uh good morning everybody
um so our first panel we're delighted to
welcome on the screen professor allen
bogg from the university of bristol and
professor jason chu from city law school
and in the room andrew burns qc good
morning to all three of you
first question please from simon chupp
thank you chair much appreciated the key
question i think
with this session is
what p ferries have done
is it legal in this country and andrea
if i can come to you first
the law requires any employer that is
contemplating making redundancies on a
large scale
to give two things first to give notice
to the secretary of state
and second to consult with the
appropriate representatives there is a
specific provision
for
employers who have employees on ships
that are flagged
in other countries apart from the united
kingdom
and that is that
45 days before the first dismissal
the company must give
notice to the appropriate country where
the authority of the country where the
ship is flagged
so there are two matters
i can't
say whether or not what's happened is
legal not because i'm not instructed on
any of the cases i don't know the exact
facts i know what
i've been
broadly told and so obviously what i say
comes with that
caveat but in broad terms all employers
all employers with ships must give a
notice the appropriate authority 45 days
before the first dismissal and my
understanding from what i've been told
this morning is that the
notice was given to the appropriate
authorities in the uh countries where
the ships were flagged only on the day
of the dismissals and not in advance
that appears to be a a breach of section
194
193a
intentionally potentially 194 which is
the provision which means that there's
unlimited fine for failure to notify the
secretary of state
and if 194 is
looked at in the light of 193a the
amendments which are made for
companies which have ships flagged
overseas then it may be that they are
liable to a prosecution
the second point is that they are
indeed potentially liable for claims be
made for protective awards
of up to 90 days pay
from
all of the 800 employees
who
were made redundant without
the notice going to their appropriate
representatives in this case i suspect
the imt union
and
for consultation
and
the law says it's quite clear
and it's abided by in my experience in
the vast vast majority of cases which is
why the circumstances we are facing
today are so unusual
employers will
at least 45 days before
the first dismissal and normally before
that because the obligation is to do it
in good time
when redundancies are first proposed by
the management of the company
they must provide inviting to the the
union or the appropriate representatives
some statutory information and that is
done in my experience in the vast
majority of cases and
also hr ones are
supplied in the vast majority of cases i
only know one other case where an hr1
was not supplied and that was a citylink
case
where the company effectively was on the
brink of collapse on the 22nd of
december and that thing didn't collapse
until christmas eve and the hr1 was
served on boxing day
so very different circumstances to
to this but i think
that's the only previous prosecution
that i know about
so i can't tell you whether this
particular case was lawful or not but
that's the context of two of the broad
matters plainly other legalities
involved
were the workers sacked fairly unfairly
they paid they may have individual
claims under dismissal
is there a transfer of undertaking
between
piano ferries and the new company which
is supplying the agency workers
potentially there might be
there's a
potentially even
maybe discrimination if there is a
nationality uh element to who was
dismissed and who was not dismissed
there's a number of different options
this appears to be a case which engages
quite a number of the employment law
rights that people
who are employed in the united kingdom
are subject to thank you very full
samantha
i just want to understand really
uh as you can explain to the committee
and those watching to what extent this
matter is a matter for uk law
international law because actually this
practice has been done before you know
that we'll talk about flagging later on
in this session but this practice is
commonplace but not on this scale
so
is this a bit of a gray area between uk
and international law
there will always be
a dividing line between
the extent to which uk employment law
can intervene in a person who is
employed not entirely within the uk and
there are there's a body of case law
about people who are employed in
different countries but have
are based here or have attachment here
and there is a
parliament has decided not to
legislate
in specifically to say who is
and who is out of uk employment law
but leave it to the courts and the
courts have filled that gap by putting
together a body of case law to say who
is ordinarily working in it's actually
great britain is the language it's used
rather than the united kingdom
and
the difficulty comes that the different
provisions of employment law sometimes
have different
jurisdictional
limits so for instance national minimum
wage applies if you are ordinarily
working in
the united kingdom
and that doesn't apply to territorial
waters it doesn't apply to international
waters but it would apply when you're
working in your port at your base for
instance
so
one thing that the committee could
consider is whether or not it's
important
now for
parliament to fill that gap that has
been filled by the courts up until now
and legislate more particularly about
who is covered by uk employment law and
who is not
just on that point then on the uk
employment law there's been an awful lot
on social media regarding the the
concept that this and what piano have
done was only possible because of a
brexit or the fact that fire and rehire
legislation wasn't agreed to by
parliament in the last uh last couple of
months is there any truth in that
i am the higher legislation is
irrelevant to this because uh
what pno have decided to do is not
which what many employers would have
done which is say to the employees will
you change your terms in order to make
us more commercially viable and then go
into negotiations with the employees and
their unions to decide whether or not
and that has been done
successfully it's been hard but
centrica british airways over the last
couple years they came in for a lot of
flak but they successfully consulted
with unions and they reached
for all or most their employees deals
for doing that process so
certainly there is that
uh
example that it does work has worked
on many occasions it's very unusual for
a company not to attempt it at all in in
my experience
and
you've talked about how
some of the legal implications of this
what steps could the government take at
this stage
to do something about this
retrospectively now
i should say i've probably been
dominating conversation i wonder with
that i will open it up in a moment don't
worry but you know what what would in
your mind be the steps the government
can take at this stage
when the first thing that a union or
employees know about dismissal is being
told that it's happening now
it's quite difficult for the courts to
intervene because
the courts generally won't grant an
injunction to force somebody to employ
workers and have an active uh
employment relationship with them there
are some cases in which employers are
forced to keep employees on the books
whilst the disciplinary process has
gone through and there's been a recent
case involving tesco in which courts
have unusually said that
dismissals in order to re-engage on
lesser terms
was unlawful and could be subject to an
injunction
but
generally
although
fire and be higher has been much
criticized by politicians and others
it is subject to reasonableness and it
may be that the reason it hadn't didn't
happen in this case is that
a view was taken that it wouldn't be
reasonable in these circumstances to
fire me higher because you can only fire
and be higher lawfully
if an employment tribunal finds that
it'd be reasonable to do so and that is
a huge break on fire we hire because and
new legislation i think
my personal view is that that doesn't
help because we've already got the
reasonableness test and the reason that
employers do think very hard and long
before they do fire and be higher is
because
the
penalties of getting it wrong
are financially very significant and
reasonableness is a very good test
because if it's reasonable to fire me
higher why should it not be lawful to do
so thank you i'll open it up to alan and
jason if i may some of the points have
been covered uh specifically around the
the your interpretation of whether pno
have acted legally in this
case uh alan if i can come to you first
yeah thank you so so i mean i i'd as a
lawyer i'd have the same caveats um as
andrew as abby's so i you know i'm not
familiar with the detail of the facts uh
and uh before i came to a conclusive
view
i would need to understand exactly what
happened and be privy to the contracts
and the time frames but
on the on what i know
there's absolutely
no doubt that wouldn't be true there's
very little doubt in my mind
uh that what has occurred involves
multiple breaches
of
labor legislation so the collective
redundancy provisions
uh
dismissal
perhaps discrimination law
and i could go on
so i think in legal terms and what
happened was so blatant
and so outrageous
that there can be very little argument
about whether the law
covered it
the key issue is an issue of remedies
and a lack of effective remedies in
situations of this nature
and for me that should be the focus
for the government as it now looks at
piano within the wider context of an
enforcement crisis in uk employment law
jason i think you'd like to add to that
so uh take an example of a breach of
collective redundancy procedure
so there is actually a penal award for
that and that's leaving aside the
possible criminal penalties
which may be more controversial
but for breach of the consultation
procedure there is the protective award
which is extensive um
it's capped at 90 days
but there's no limit on weekly pay for
that purpose so it can be quite a
significant financial remedy
but for a company with the financial
heft
of pno
the fact is there is a cap
on the protective award the employer can
calculate in advance
what its financial like liabilities will
be
and it can then effectively buy itself
out of the rule of law by offering
compensation packages that go beyond
what the legal remedies would be
so i think uh in this kind of situation
i would be in favor of removing
caps and limitations on remedies
in situations where you have such a
gross violation of employment laws as
you have here because it removes the
possibility
of efficient breach which is an affront
to the rule of law it's effectively
buying out of the legal system
jason is anything like to add to alan
and andrew's testimony so far
thank you um
can you hear can you hear me we can hear
you loud and clear
perfect thank you and
i should add a health warning to what
i'm about to comment on
obviously i'm a maritime lawyer so i'm
going to be focusing largely on the
seafarers side of things rather than
employment rights in general so the
questions raise concern
i think number one
um legality of what you know fairies
have done and number two
what can be done as far as the
government is concerned or
any other stakeholders
so i think
as far as legality is concerned
um
and it was quite right to say that
notice has to be given and that actually
was a a change to our previous law uh
following the sea various directive from
the european union so that essentially
meant that the
duty to notify the secretary of state
which was
published in law before had to give way
to
a duty to notify the
place where the ship was registered and
there are three places where the ships
were registered at cyprus the mueller
and the bahamas
so it is a 45 day period notice for
cypriot registered vessels it is 30 days
for me go around for the bahamas
now
asking what the consequences are i think
i'm not an employment lawyer so i have
to stress that
but
amongst the shipping circles there is
some concern or some uh
uh
i suppose
some
troubling thought as to whether
uh
that the failure to notify the chip
registries
in these different jurisdictions
actually would attract a penalty
because the relevant section actually
simply refers to the duty they notify or
the failure to notify secretary of state
it doesn't actually refer to a failure
to notify the flag state and so
we are a little bit unsure
as to whether
the failure to notify within those set
parameters would attract any kind of
sanctions under
the trade unions and labor relations act
so
that's one aspect of i think the
discussion that has been going on so far
the so
back to your
secondary question earlier about to what
extent
has brexit got to do with this um to
some extent i suppose one could say that
the dispensation of the requirement to
notify the secretary of state was
actually introduced by eu law
and that has been tapped as retained eu
law and but of course with practicing it
is now possible for uh parliament if
so desires to change that and move it
back to a duty to notify the secretary
of state rather than uh the flag states
uh registries so um let me pause there
and see if there is any follow-up
question and then i could move on
to other aspects
and hopefully some of your questions
will be honest later in this session
i'll hand over my colleague nasrat ghani
thank you so much um so it's been made
clear that the their obligations because
of where they were flagged would have
been to the states where they were
flagged but professor bogg you talked
about the multiple breaches in in
managing the way that the employees were
dismissed and you talked about what can
can take place next and i wondered if
you thought there was any
um
any support for the idea that
theoretically because of the multiple
breaches that you've spoken about
there could be a way of seeking an
injunction restraining p a from
breaching uk employment law i know
injunctions are very rarely granted but
because there are so many people
involved employees 800 and there seem to
be quite a few breaches in the uk
employment role in how you
explain or conduct a consultation
how a redundancy could take place what
do you think professor could there be an
injunction
thank you very much for that question so
um it's possible for there to be an
injunction
in circumstances uh like this but it
would depend upon what was in the
individual contracts of employment
and whether there were specific
procedures
that have been incorporated from a
collective agreement
into the individual contract now that
can sometimes be difficult because
collective procedures
as the courts would say are are not act
for incorporation
sometimes so at the current time
i think it's very difficult to give a
definitive answer what i can say is that
there are um obstacles to seeking
injunctive relief
but um if i may say i think that
provides um another argument
in favor of statutory reform
to give a provision in a case of this
nature
to free standing interim relief under
the statutes so what you would say is
you don't need to look at the contract
you simply identify and anticipate a
breach of the statutory consultation
procedure
and the statute then gives an option for
interim relief which is what you have in
trade union dismissal cases so it's
possible to go to the court to get
interim really to keep the contract on a
footing until the issue has been
considered by the court so i i think
it's possible
uh but there are difficulties but in
terms of reform priorities um i
absolutely think
that this should be something to be
considered and also
in the fire and rehire bill
um
in the detail of that bill
my recollection is that there was
provision
in clause two of the barry gardner bill
for injunctive relief in situations work
fire and rehire was in breach of
procedure
um so um there's no question this isn't
a fire and re-hire situation but this is
fire and rehire on steroids
these are things that are on the same
spectrum of contractual deregulation so
i think what i would push back at andrew
by saying is that the failure
to deal with fire and rehire a set a
broader tone
about the seriousness with which
parliament takes enforcement and that i
think can encourage a culture of
impunity which is maybe what we've seen
here
thank you professor bog because this is
an extraordinary situation one could
then apply extraordinary um
responses which could then theoretically
be an injunction my next question i'll
keep it short i do need super short
answers i'm afraid and i'll go to andrew
yourself first um in legal terms has
piano ad adequately demonstrated a
business needed to reduce staff numbers
and if they had what would that look
like
my understanding they aren't reducing
staff numbers they are contracting out
and having the same number of staff but
rather than being employed in-house by
piano ferries
being contracted in from an external
company and we all know that many many
companies have found it commercially
advantageous to rather than employ their
own staff to contract in from third
parties that provide that staff
this is
i think
unusual to do it
to this scale but
what makes this case unusual is not
contracting out
but
contracting out with no notice and
telling everybody on the day and the
reason it's
here is because this almost never
happens and the reason it almost never
happens is that we do have
very really serious financial penalties
compensatory penalties for employers who
don't follow the rules about
notification and consultation and so one
thing i would say is that although there
might be a
knee-jerk reaction to then law needs to
change stop this happening
we we obviously all need to consider
that it happens really really
infrequently because the present legal
system does impose really really
significant financial penalties against
employers that don't give any notice at
all thank you i think my time has run
out thank you chairman
thank you just two very um quick wash up
questions um from me mr burns it's been
suggested that p a ferries might say
that their contracts of employment are
based in jersey and the employ and the
leadership in jersey made the decision
to make the staff redundant
if that was the case does uk law bite
uk law yes can bite because the
employment tribunals don't look just at
what the contract says
the employment tribunals look at the
reality of the situation they look at
where employees are based in reality and
that's often looks where they're
assigned to so if the employees in this
case had bases in dover or hull or
places like that where they checked in
where they were managed where their
employment was administered from
there is a real likelihood that uk law
and employment tribunals jurisdiction
will apply to them whereas somebody
who's based overseas where their manager
is overseas where they're paid overseas
where they're taxed overseas and what
the employment treadmill does is look at
a arrange a package
of factors to see whether or not uk
employment law has the closest
connection to to their employment so the
fact that the employer is based
has an office overseas or
the contract which says this is subject
to a different law it isn't the fact of
which wins thank you and professor chu
if piano ferries didn't adequately
notify
uh the cypriot uh
bermuda or bahaman
competent authorities within sufficient
time is that a breach of uk law
according to the trade unions and labour
relations act it would be a breach of uk
law because it is quite plain in the in
that statute that they need to notify
these flags states registries however as
i was saying earlier there may be a
question as to what the penalties may be
because the penalty uh provision
relating to notice doesn't actually
specify this particular seafaring uh
category and that is perhaps a gap in
the law which could be plucked uh
hopefully in the future thank you hugh
merman um thank you chair um andrew i
perhaps i'll put this to you because you
raised it the prime minister said that
the government will ensure that mariners
working in uk waters are paid the living
wage
is that a matter solely for parliament
to to legislate to cause that to occur
or are there international obligations
in maritime you're aware of that could
uh cause that to be impossible national
minimum wage is domestic legislation
it's unrelated to
our membership of the eu it was
something we put in domestically and we
can
we can enforce that as long as there's a
con connection between the companies and
the employees in the uk we plainly can't
say that somebody who's employed at the
other side of the world by a company on
the other side of the world she paid a
certain amount of money that's obviously
ridiculous but if there's a connection
with the uk it seems to me that we can
we could legislate to
potentially make the national minimum
wage apply to let's say uk territorial
waters at the moment the legislation
says it doesn't so my understanding is
at the moment you would be able to
enforce the national minimum wage
between say ferris going scotland
northern ireland but not between dover
and calais but you believe there should
be a way for parliament to make that
that happen
parliament could amend the legislation
in relation to seafarers at which
there are specific provisions in
relation to minimum wage for seafarers
on uk flagships and seafarers on new
non-uk flagships and at the moment
the national minimum wage applies to the
time when they're ordinarily in great
britain or they're working they're based
here so when they're on shore and doing
their preparation and so forth but i
think as soon as they go
into waters i think we've we've chosen
parliament's chosen that the national
way shouldn't apply to them
at that point sorry last part so
bizarrely it could be that if you're
going from dover to calais the time that
you are in
the english waters on on that straight
you could actually apply the minimum
wage then for that part i'm sure
hopefully the french would do the same
with their minimum wage on the other
side at the moment i think
that the and i haven't looked at this in
real detail but i think that the
national minimum wage will only apply uh
while they're in port
may i come in on that i i apologize i i
i'm
i've done a bit of work around the
minimum wage for seafarers within
territorial waters and continental shelf
uh so
the
national minimum wage for uh offshore
employment order
was amended in 2020
and so that now places uh the
requirement to pay national minimum wage
for anyone who works or ordinarily works
in uk territorial waters
or
in the uk sector of the continental
shelf
so this means that if we were
uh if we have a a seafarer working on a
vessel which is sailing from northern
ireland to scotland
they will be covered by the national
minimum wage and if we were sailing from
england to ireland
then
we will hit
a non-confidential shelf waltons then we
would
it raises the question as to whether
that sea barrier would be covered by
a amendment introduced in 2020. so this
is an anomaly which i know that uh
parliament had uh
deliberated over previously in uh uh
2020.
so
professionally sorry sorry to interrupt
but i'm very conscious of time if you
could write to us with the detail of
that we'd be very grateful
but i've got one very last quick
question on this panel from ben bradshaw
professor borg just very briefly um are
there any significant differences in
french and dutch label or which have led
to piano not treating those workers in
the same way
so so i i think that the position uh in
in both of those jurisdictions would be
that the there are more significant
restrictions
in place
for uh failures to consult of this kind
uh and the difference would be in the
remedies and enforcement uh and the
possibility that dismissals might be uh
amenable to an injunction or might even
be null and void because they've been
undertaken in breach of procedures if
you could write to us with a bit more
detail on that i think we'd be very
grateful
of course uh one very quick point if i
may um i really uh very i remember i'm
sorry i'm sorry it's cut it off press
the button but i've got five panels of
witnesses to get through but of course
you're very welcome to write to us and
we'd be very grateful all right i'll
i'll send you a note thank you so much
i'm grateful thank you to our three
witnesses for our first panel we're now
going to move swiftly on to
panel two uh with representatives from
trade unions uh we have mark dickinson
who's the general secretary from
nautilus international and mike lynch
who's the general secretary of the rmt
we'll just let you take your
seats
thank you good morning to both you
gentlemen thank you for coming in at
short notice um first questions are from
alan brown please yeah thanks sir um
just quite with him mark um i've seen a
response from p o fairies back to the um
base department where they argue that
when they've done the notification on
the day they did do a personal
notification to seafarers on the ships
rather than the reported same or
pre-recorded messages is that right or
is pino at it with that
my understanding is that they the vast
majority of our members heard about this
via video
via this zoom uh call other members who
were obviously rostered off got all
sorts of communications couriers
uh
postal services but i mean if you're not
in the house you don't get the message
some of our people have still not had
their packages is my understanding they
don't know what the company's going to
reward them or award them with
and so they're in a very difficult
position
and pno
have said that they've got access to
these lawyers they're not getting access
to lawyers because the lawyers can't
cope with the amount of um
traffic coming their way so some of our
people have still had no advice
from the lawyers that piano have put up
so they're in a very difficult position
and they're also facing the this like
this
peculiar situation where all these
eminent people
up to the level of the prime minister
are discussing their future
and
qcs and professors about the law
nobody's discussing as far as i can see
how we're going to get these people back
to work
because this company has made flagrant
breaches of the law has just been
described they've done it deliberately
and they've factored in what they're
going to have to pay for it and they're
threatening it and blackmailing our
people that if you do not sign this
document by next thursday you will be
out of work and you will potentially get
no award whatsoever and you have to give
up
all of your legal rights to take this
company to task this is absolutely
outrageous so not only is it calculating
in terms of what they've got to pay
they brought into life this company
lmf in moore six weeks ago it didn't
exist
so they're chooping people to a company
that doesn't exist and they're informing
people behind a brass plate
in bermuda the bahamas and malta and
cyprus about our members future in
county and trim so what are you going to
do phone up somebody in the bahamas and
say i'm getting rid of a hundred of your
people in county antrim
and not tell their representatives the
whole thing is a setup
and the law in this country is a
shambles
and the politicians and the lawyers in
this country have watched over the last
30 years
while not only workers have been made
vulnerable but our merchant marine has
been decimated and destroyed and if this
goes the way it's likely to go from what
i've seen
we won't have a merchant navy in this
country there will be no ratings working
out of british ports and on british
ships british ships will choose to exist
and british ratings will cease to exist
and that's what p o are aiming to
achieve to kill our
merchant marine and to kill our
employment laws and something's got to
be done about it today
the prime minister said he's going to
prosecute this government has got to
intervene now impound these ships and
get our people back to work and then
we'll sort out the law after
okay um
[Music]
obviously that's your kiosk is
impounding legal action the government
seem to be doing something is there any
any other kiosk that actually gets your
employees back working
well the key ask is is that we put a
safety regime and get some safety
inspections that are not just
uh superficial i've got no faith that
piano will run these these vessels
safely and maybe mark will have some
more comments on there but we have got a
desperate race by piano to get these
vessels back out on the seas they we
understand they moved one of them last
night to empty uh
hull to get people over on an empty
voyage over to
to rotterdam they are desperate to get
this back on the seas and they think
it's all going to blow over as soon as
they've got discount
uh prices out to the hauliers uh and to
the public and they think it's all going
to blow over the government must do
something the only people with power in
this situation
are the ministers of the crown they're
either going to sit there and watch this
happen or they're going to get the mca
to impound those ships and not let them
travel
piano has already taken them out of the
port so they're outside your
jurisdiction so not only do they have
contempt for the law they have contempt
for your house you discussed it
yesterday and what did they do last
night move one of the vessels outside
your jurisdiction
so our ask is for intervention
i don't mind which intervention it is as
long as you stop pno
breaking the law
and putting two fingers up to every
member of this house and potentially
uh completely diluting employment law in
this country what was said about that
again
just then to ask mark about the safety
concerns that might be saying you'd want
to comment and also can you outline
what uk companies have been complicit in
us in terms of bringing in this new
staff to take over because that that's
clearly a key issue as well
thank you thank you alan for the for the
question and uh i'd
very much like to associate
myself with mick's uh
comments
about the situation that our members
face
now the the issue around the safety case
this has been a long running discussion
with piano uh uh pinot ferries over the
years i'll take dover as an example
because in a way it's the most extreme
example because in dover to calais
you're running passenger and freight
vessels across the busiest shipping lane
in the world and you're
crossing it at essentially
you know right angles that's the way
that's the way it works and the traffic
is moving
up and down in the in the separation
zones it's an incredibly uh
incredibly dangerous
situation and you need skilled qualified
experienced maritime professionals
both mixed members of my own members on
board the vessels
to cope with that they do
ten crossings a day
and they do
12 hours
a day
two shifts obviously to cover the
24-hour such situation to two crews four
crews
in in total
and
we already know we can already see and
they've tried it with us time and time
again they want to move to two weeks on
and two weeks off so that's two weeks on
working 12 hour shifts
looking after the safety of passengers
and truck drivers
moving to freight
so
this
for us is
one of the key issues and we have spoken
to the company we've discussed this with
the company i mean in 2012 they
conducted a
a a research
project and produced a paper with
cardiff university
to look at the working patterns on board
and you know from from my sense of that
that's where one week on and one week
off is derived from and we don't believe
it's safe in the past we've made
proposals to the company to increase the
manning of of of crew in order to cope
with a potential two week on two week
off but the company rejected those
proposals so we have maintained for the
safety of those on board not just our
own members but the passengers and the
lorry drivers who we transport across on
those vessels that one week on and one
week off is the appropriate and for me
that's one of the key issues and it goes
to the heart of the safety case alan and
mick mentioned that you've you've
questioned me on now
beyond that and this speaks really to
the issue
of whether these vessels
can with a new crew or with a
substantial number of replacement crew
being drafted in
to replace the saxy for us
whether they can be readied in in a
matter of days to conduct and
reintroduce their services in a safe way
and we do not believe that that can
that can be can be done there are
obviously
international
rules about these issues sdcw standards
of training and conventional watch
keeping convention from the imo there's
the international
safety management code ism code our
estimation our view that actually in the
scenario that we are facing it could
take months not days to prepare
a crew
to safely operate those vessels
i i i can see there are probably more
questions so i'll probably limit my
answer to that
um if you could come back on and ask
about uk companies being complicit
because clearly has been a very covert
operation with pno
um to spring the surprise what what what
companies have actually helped them in
terms of trying to restart the shirts
absolutely i would i would highlight two
in particular that i'm aware of that i
believe and the evidence suggests have
been central to enabling piano ferries
to introduce
their their mass sacking of ukc for as a
replacement of uh
recruitment of their replacements and
that would be colombia ship management
of cyprus and clyde marine
of the uk glasgow i i believe they're
based there are one or two others um
that have been quick to deny any
involvement but some of the jobs they've
been advertising look suspiciously like
they are the jobs
that that have been uh that have been
vacated or that our members have been
sacked from um but those two are the
other principal companies that i would
name uh
okay and i'm gonna have to hand up a
call very shortly but
and we heard earlier on there that
the crossing from scotland to northern
ireland is wholly within uk waters so
therefore the minimum wage shouldn't be
breached at all what what terms and
conditions are pino trying to put on
staff
that they're trying to you know
move into um that crossing and would it
reach the minimum wage in the uk
well my understanding is that they'd
have to pay the minimum wage on that
crossing for ratings but
that
they will be without pension they will
be without any terms and conditions
there without holiday pay there will
just be voyage only so it'll be for the
hours they're on on board that ship
there'll be no
conditions associated with but we'll
have to see um
they will use whatever they can use and
at the minute they're desperate to get
people because people are walking off
their ships
is their understanding but
we believe that they would have to honor
the national minimum wage but of course
our members weren't getting paid the
minimum wage our members were getting
paid negotiated decent terms and
conditions so any step down to the
minimum wage is a dilution of what we
already had they've broken the union
agreements they're also about companies
just very quickly ellen they're
undermining every other seafaring
company in this country we've got good
agreements with stenner and dfds
what are they going to do how will they
compete with this piracy on our on our
shores
and they're really concerned about that
and we're really concerned about our
members we could end up with a a race to
the bottom initiated by piano and i
think that's what it's designed to do to
be pino and facilitated by clyde marine
exactly and we've had it with irish
ferris irish ferries have done exactly
this this procedure already
thank you thank you chris later please
uh thank you chairman uh good morning
gentlemen it's good to have you with us
today
the first question i had for you is
could you confirm to your knowledge is
this
uh a matter for uk workforce or piano
ferries only or are there other
workforces in other countries that are
affected do you know
thanks for the question chris um
you know my union sorry it's a
straightforward answer yeah okay are
there and if so where are the countries
please no it's uk only lovely thank you
very much
i understand that there are 786
uh people who've been affected by these
redundancies
could you just tell me what percentage
of those 786 are rnt members and also
uh mark of your union
roughly so of those 786 about 450
rmt members
i presume the rest would be nautilus
members
okay so so so maybe
60 40-ish okay and of the wider
workforce those who are not being made
redundant are you aware of the number of
staff that are not being made redundant
so i i'm sorry i don't know the wider
workforce number
they said it's something about something
above 2 000. but we that will be
administrative market in finance they're
not within our
rnc this is the entire seafaring
workforce that's very helpful uk
those who are being made redundant you
mentioned just now that they were paid
above the minimum wage
were those who've been made redundant
paid above
the living wage
absolutely yeah properly negotiated you
know there's a whole scale of salaries
right up from the master who's a
professional status to the people
working in the canteen that's the same
for i'm seeing on the same terms and
conditions great okay um
when were the last negotiations that the
unions would have had with pno about
terms and conditions
i haven't got the dates on a regular
cycle we could have been a two-year deal
but what i would say we've got no beef
with piano we're not in a dispute
we were meant to meet them on the 18th
about their prospects for new vessels
which would be about new staffing i'm
assuming mark's union was as well new
crew in procedures
instead of honoring that meeting they
sacked all their members on st patrick's
day some patrick's day massacre you
might call it yeah but the last one
so in terms of the last negotiations
would you say what was 12 months ago
i haven't got that figure but it would
be on a regular cycle
so i just wondered if both of you could
confirm that at those last negotiations
piano ferries will have given both of
your unions and the mp for dover the
assurances that those negotiations were
going to safeguard the future of piano
if you can't answer it today i
understand that because your respective
roles we would very much appreciate it
if you would write to the committee and
confirm if you could have maybe consult
the regional organizer because i think
this is a very important point i'm i've
been informed
um by those who have an interest that
actually assurances were made
to the unions and to the mp for dover
that uh
that those negotiations were going to
safeguard the future so so that would be
really good uh to understand and could i
just ask um the employers affected where
actually are they based
so for dover many of them are in the
dover kent area
but
the way that seafaring works and the way
that it's been in decline we've got so
we'll have members from ireland the
republic and the north
working at hull we may have people from
great britain working
in ireland so but in dover they are
concentrated around that area but people
do travel across the uk some people live
abroad yeah so the people who are
affected by this redundancy they are
dover-based
and any other bases they're not not you
know they're not all dover-based i mean
they're based
often they work in the vicinity of the
port simply for
convenience for joining the the ships in
their regular rotation so there will be
substantial numbers in the dover area in
the whole area liverpool ken ryan long
um liverpool did i mention liverpool
where i'm from there'll be significant
numbers all these spaces have been
affected by the streets yeah absolutely
all of them yeah wonderful
could you just confirm to your knowledge
whether or not staff were
physically and forcibly removed from
ships
what i can confirm is that security
personnel came on board
in security outfits that our members
were told they had to leave the ship
immediately they were escorted to their
lockers and their cabins because our
people live on these things for
seven days at a time so they got their
own personal effects the
you know their part-time home
they were made to load those into
plastic bags and until they did that
they would not receive the packages
the packets containing the information
about their
dismissal and therefore the
the compensation as they might call it
so i don't i haven't heard of any force
or any restraint or anything like that
but there was intimidation in the sense
you had four or five security guards
standing around individuals or groups of
individuals saying you must go to your
cabin now clear out your stuff and
remove yourself from the vessel
understand and i'll just come back to
you mark just a moment i understand um
and i referenced the bbc and the
independent
that a leaked email that was reported
actually suggested a company called
interforce was engaged by piano
and a little bit of research tells me
that intervals are handcuffed trained
security professionals
are you aware of handcuffs being used to
remove forcibly removed
i'm not aware of any incident i don't
know whether mick is directly of uh the
handcuffs being deployed but uh been
some suggestion
i think from the company that though
nobody was wearing balaclavas well i
have information i have reports from my
members that that's not correct they
were some were wearing alex what ship
that was like i can't but maybe i can
you would writers and tell us i'm sure
we'd appreciate what i would say
and i just want to follow up the point
mick made about
our members live on these vessels for
varying periods i've just received this
morning a photograph
of the personal effects of crew that was
sacked in bin bags on the deck of the
pride of kent by skips ready to be
thrown in the bin just like the
seafarers who've lost their jobs and i'm
i'm sorry but that is that's the most
disgraceful thing
beyond what happened one week ago this
day that's just a new low and i'm really
shocked by it
would you just would you agree that this
is the most extreme form of corporate
mass bullying you have ever seen in your
in your career so far i
mick and i um have been spending a lot
of time together over the past seven
days
and uh and the the the anger that we
feel is real i said not angry at being
with him by the way i've learned he's a
hell of a nice guy
i'm not sure the pinot ferries intended
to throw uh nautilus into the arms of
the rnt or or likewise that's what's
happening is what i'm asking so the
answer to that straight question is
absolutely shocking i've never seen
anything like it in 44 years shipping
you agree what i've said sorry thank you
very much well it i'm an electrician and
i was backlisted from construction
that's why i'm on the railway and i have
ended up on this job and i had to take
uh mcalpine's and uh group to the high
court to get that settled along with
three thousand others so there are other
examples
of corporate hostility
but that that made us paranoid because
we couldn't see it all the time this is
when it's in your face this is probably
the most extreme i've seen in my career
and i've never seen a reputable company
destroy its reputation in such a quick
time thank you
could you i just want to go on now to
what staff have been offered
um
first of all could you confirm that it's
your understanding
that all staff affected by redundancies
have been told they must sign a
non-disclosure agreement
otherwise there is no discussion no
negotiation and nothing to be uh
to be offered in terms of
recommendations yeah my understanding
our members have got um
settlement agreements they're called
which have got non-disclosure in them so
it's at a rate of two and a half weeks
per year everybody's saying this is so
generous that is under the level that we
negotiate on the railway and many other
companies it's not that generous they've
given them 13 weeks to pay in lieu of
notice because they never gave them any
notice so they have to give them that
and they've built in this that the qc
was talking about a protective award
they factored that in
and you have to sign that you will not
take any legal cases for any issue
against pno and our understanding as
well is that you can never talk about
pno in the open at any time in the
future and if you don't do that you'll
you'll have to take them to tribunal for
the statutory award of only one one week
per year of service
i think we've been clear on the
undiscovered stream could you just find
me because i've got to hand back the
chairman shortly can you just finally
tell us
what have the staff affected by this
redundancy actually been offered by the
company that you know of
two and a half weeks per year service
they've been given 13 weeks pay in lieu
of notice they haven't been given it
it's in the document
and a 13-week compensatory award to buy
off the tribunal case and if they don't
sign it
they would have to take the statutory
minimum awarded by the government
at capped rates so it's blackmail in our
view
could i just add it as times
um
the point made earlier that there's no
rehire involved in this well actually
the companies put it in writing they
want 91 of my members to come back and
in addition to the the package that
mick has outlined
they're offering a uh re-sign bonus of
uh which will be payable in 12 months
time
um and if they accept that today so
there's an additional pressure on my
members to sign today no later than
today and if they don't sign by today
but signed by next week that bonus offer
is reduced by half
91
the the accruing strategy is in tatters
because they didn't plan to do any of
this rehire they plan to replace
everybody with ukrainian seafoods and
russian seafarers and for obvious
reasons
that part of the plan is in
so this is this plan if you can call it
a plan is plan b
and i thank you gentlemen very much
indeed for answering your questions back
to you thank you so much
thank you so much i must put on record
that i am a trustee of the charity the
seafarers charity mr dickinson you're a
trustee as well my questions are to you
the two short questions hopefully you
can respond in short um answers too i'm
anxious about one of the the lines of
question that mr brown had and i want to
make it clear that i've been having some
private messages or dms from people on
board the ship and they were not made
aware of where they were being sent to
they weren't aware that they were going
to go to a piano ferry destination and
there's huge anxiety that what they've
been caught up in as well so this has
just been dreadful for everybody
involved and i don't want any for them
to feel any more anxious and frightened
and threatened either do you agree mr
dickinson i agree and that's correct i
have uh same information i've been
receiving from members thank you mr now
you're also anxious as much as i am that
piano fairies thought they could turn
this around in just 10 days consider the
lack of experience and knowledge of crew
board where do you think they would have
come up with that number of 10 days do
you think there were any conversations
with anybody for them to be comfortable
they could have those ships safe and
ready to sell in 10 days i don't think
anybody that knows the maritime industry
or would consider themselves to be a
maritime expert or a maritime
professional would have come up with a
figure of 10 days so you would you agree
with me that they would be impossible
for them to comply with the standards of
training certification and watch keeping
stcw or the icm code international
safety management code within 10 days no
you agree that it would be possible no
sorry i would agree that it wouldn't be
possible thank you so much thank you mr
dickinson thank you very much well thank
you mike lynch and mark dickinson for
your contributions this morning we're
grateful to uh both of you we're now
moving on to our third of five panels
this morning
and we'll be welcoming dean beal who's
the chief executive officer
at the insolvency service
brian johnson who's the chief executive
of the maritime and coast guard agency
and casey ware who is the director of uk
maritime
services
all three of whom are with us in the
room this morning
uh we'll just let you get comfortable
great and the first question is from
hugh merriman
uh thank you chair um perhaps we'll
start with the maritime and coastal
agency if i may and i know that
i know that uh my colleague wants to
carry on so the secretary of state has
said that you as an agency will be going
in to inspect the ships from a safety
perspective
um can you tell us what you've been
doing so far what you've found and
whether you consider this new crew to be
safe to sail
can i maybe just give a little bit of
just a little bit of context a little
bit yeah um so we operate within uh an
international framework set by the
international maritime organization the
un agency
and
every ship is flagged with the state
the flag state and that's the state
whose legislation holds on board the
ship
and the international conventions lay
down the accountability of the flag
state so for these particular ships
cyprus bahamas bermuda lay down the
accountabilities for the flag state
which are the primary accountabilities
around the hardware the equipment the
manning
the experience the
competencies of the crew
living underneath that
for each nation that a ship visits
is the port state responsibilities
that's like a
safety net
in this case for the uk
to check that we're comfortable that the
flag state has fulfilled its primary
responsibilities so sorry that's the
broad context for probably a lot of what
katie and i might talk about today so
actually in a way
even if the sort of cypriot requirements
have not been met you can ensure that
the uk standards have to be met not just
in port but all the way through the
journey as well
it's the cypriot standards that there
are minimum standards that have to be
met internationally and the specific
standards on board the ships are set by
the cypriot you're
the safety envelope that we would
require we would require within the uk
uh but let me just be absolutely clear
here so
are you looking at the uk safety rule
book and applying that or are you
actually looking at the city right
safety rules
there are universal safety standards
that have to be applied on on shipping
and those are those of what we would
apply so those include for example as
previous witnesses talked about sdcw
the maritime labour convention
the
ism the the international safety
management system so we would ensure
that those are those are being applied
okay let me ask you another way around
so if they were actually registered in
the uk and cyprus wasn't in existence
would there be any difference in the
type of safety regime you'd go in and
look yes yes i would because we would
have dual accountability we would have
flag state accountability so that
primary uh overview accountability for
all the standards on the ship and we'd
be looking at it from this safety
safety fallback position which is the
port state regime right okay so let's
let's drill in now to what you've
actually so the secretary of state's
been very bold in house of commons and
said you're going onto those ships to
inspect them what have you what have you
done so far
so uh the pride of hull which sailed
yesterday probably uh it is is the one
that we've been most engaged with
we went in we did
full port state inspections and those
those cover
um
the certification of the crew
certification of the vessel
certification acidification of the crew
includes
what qualifications they've got
it would look at hardware it would look
at key safety drills actually run
through those do those safety drills
live with the crew so it's katie katie
can describe in a little bit more detail
if if that's helpful but uh essentially
we'd be covering that we we covered all
of that off you signed off on it
correct uh and and on that vessel how
many new crew were there what percentage
would you say 18 in total were new 18
new crew new crew correct and how many
crew and total were there can i
see that 710
crew on board 18 when you
okay right so a small percentage is that
the sort of percentages you're expecting
say for example the dover calais
ships because obviously there's a heck
of a lot of people have been we've been
told all the seafarers have been made
redundant or sacked so that's a small
percentage
i'm not sure we're clear about exactly
what that situation is going going to
look like at the moment the piano
ferrets believe that they'll soon in
days be able to move their ferries from
dover
how long will it actually take in this
situation for you to fully inspect and
sign off do you believe
an inspection would take
one day minimum uh could be could be
slightly longer than that depending on
what's found
give us an example if if you've got a
completely new crew say or you know
there's a much greater percentage and so
how long is that like i mean
surely it will take you a heck of a long
time to make sure that every single
person who's come on board that ship
who's not been part of the ship's crew
before this is the one of the most
dangerous shipping lanes uh railroad
requirements are stricter perhaps after
the herald of free enterprise i mean
that's surely you will be taking a heck
of a long time yeah could i maybe defer
defer to katie on this one she can she
can have a little bit of she can add a
bit of color to exactly what those
inspections involve which might help
yeah we really want to know how detailed
you can make this be just to confirm for
the committee
we have not actually got the port state
control inspection scheduled for the
dover fleet yet we are waiting for
confirmation from piano with respect to
the crew and so we've not got those port
state control inspections scheduled
we would go on board that vessel
as brian has said we will inspect the
certification of the actual vessel
we will inspect the certification of
the minimum safe manning of that vessel
to ensure that they've got the right
qualifications
we will ensure that those members of the
staff and that could be hotel staff who
are responsible for dealing with
passengers during an evacuation i've got
the necessary safety familiarization
okay you can actually speak up a bit
with some of the members
so for any crew that are not operating
the vessel but are responsible for
mustering and escorting crew passengers
off the vessel when there's an emergency
we ensure that they have got their
proper familiarization around management
crowd management risk assessments etc
so when we go on board not only were we
checking the certification but we will
do full drills so we would take we would
put in place a complete fire drill we
would exercise those fire crews those
hotel stuff to make sure that they're
completely familiar
and able to evacuate their ships in an
emergency
we also for example even drill down into
making sure that those crew can take
orders and can communicate instructions
in the assigned language of the vessel
so it's a very heavily
focused operational exercise
and as brian has said that can take us
between one and two days i do not
envisage
them taking less than two days as we
just said the pride of hull we were on
the 22nd and the 23rd of march as we've
shown from the figures that is a crew
that is familiar with the ship but it
still has taken us two days to do that
port state controlled inspection okay
thank you would you speak to every
single member of crew to ascertain that
they know what they're doing can
understand as well as looking at looking
at it from a team holistic perspective
so
we would watch the for example the fire
parties the surveyors on board would
watch those fire parties to do what they
do
in terms of the crew members like the
hotel staff that are responsible for
guarding passengers through we would
talk to them and ask them questions
about what their roles and
responsibilities were so we were key
that we understood that they understand
what they're required to do
for crew that were responsible for
launching the lifeboat we would talk
directly to each individual ones of
those teams ask them to explain to us
what they're doing in terms of launching
and preparing those lifeboats we would
then watch them launch their lifeboats
maneuver those lifeboats and recover
those lifeboats so it's an intensive
discussion and you're responsible for
hours of work or rest safety management
certification of seafarers and training
of seafarers just
picking the latter up i mean obviously
you can't just pitch up
even if you've got experience and then
actually be able to operate that boat it
must take a long time to train
to train up they must have to go out to
sea
there's a highly
structured system in stcw uh which is is
the international standard for seafarer
training highly structured training
system and we'd make sure that people
were
qualified to the to the right level and
and the idea of that system
is is that it can be internationally
used and internationally applied on
board ships so we'd absolutely check
that people were
certified to the to the correct
standards on board
as well as looking as katie's described
at how they perform within the within
the drills
okay and just coming back to the the
ship that sailed from hull is it the
pride of hulk yes it was did did that uh
get signed off
did did it sail successfully and you've
certified it yes yes you did
well can i just introduce the there's a
tweet going out breaking confirmation
the mca have not given p 0 very proud of
hull permission to return to normal
operations no row packs means no
passengers it's our understanding the
vessel is on route to rotterdam for
replacement crew and safety drills
so we undertook port state control
okay can you speak up again we
understood that under the port state
control it was completed yesterday my
technical manager who leads in the
northeast confirmed to us that that
vessel was cleared by the mca to sail
piano advised us that that vessel would
sail from hull to rotterdam yesterday
evening without passengers and cargo
that vessel is due into rotterdam
she will then be presented to the dutch
administration and the dutch maritime
administration will also undertake
inspection of that vessel no road packs
what does that mean
there was no um there was no passengers
or cargo on board
they'd have to do this again with
passengers on as well and you'd be
inspecting at that point
no we won't be inspecting them again but
they're presenting the vessel to the
dutch administration before they load
passengers and cargo
my final question is what conversations
have you had with the secretary of state
about
the inspections that he feels you should
be you should be delivering what you can
do we've we've
we've been clear um uh with with
colleagues at dft that we will be
absolutely enforcing all the port state
inspections in in a really rigorous way
we've been talking with the
with the flag states as well
so
we've we understand
what cyprus bermuda and bahamas are
going to be doing in terms of
inspections of those vessels
and we've got um we've had french and
irish colleagues
who we've been in touch with who though
these port state inspections are
absolutely uk port state inspections
colleagues from uh france and uh ireland
uh also wish to witness those
questions so you've been clear but what
conversations have you had with the
secretary of state you're the chief
executive of the agency he's the
secretary of state have you had a
conversation with him or the my
conversations have been with uh my
opposite number in dft who i know has
been in contact with an official not a
minister
i can help you there chair so um
following the minister court statement
in the house on the thursday the 17th
i actually um contacted his private
office to advise him that we would be
inspecting all eight vessels
um and that we had agreed with pino that
we would be inspecting all of those
vessels
and that we advised that if we had any
safety concerns that we would obviously
enforce the regulations and if necessary
we would stop those ships from sailing
and that was i was sent that to
minister quartz's private office on
thursday the 17th would you not have
expected a minister to contact you and
say right we want to make absolutely
sure these ships are safe you look in
every nook and cranny speak to every
single person uh would you have expected
that conversation to come your way sorry
chair i should have said that that email
was in response from the minister um
seeking my assurance that then the
safety concerns would be addressed with
piano okay well i'll leave it there
because others want to come in thank you
so much thank you nizo ghani please
thank you and good morning um i've got
some quite a few questions i'll try and
keep them brief and the answers can be
brief that'd be great you talked about
the inspections taking place there is
some anxiety that inspections are taking
place without any passengers on board so
how are they the new crew expected to
evacuate
potentially up to 2 000 people in an
emergency how are you going to prove
that inspect it and authorize it miss
where
it's a difficult question to answer um
as i said i've explained how we do the
drills and the operations it is quite
normal practice for us to do it without
passengers
we very rarely use passengers for safety
reasons
as you can understand for those drills
and often when we're doing those drills
there are no passengers on board so
that's not just applicable to the
the ferries that's also the same for the
class 1 passenger vessels we don't do it
with passengers complicated because
we've got new crew in a very difficult
situation i'm now going to read out a
message that was sent to me by
a person that was arrived on the ship as
new crew they didn't know where they
were going they hadn't realized this is
where the contract was
and they sent me a message which has
given me a huge amount of anxiety
they said to me the safety of the vessel
has not been considered the crew that
i'm with have no knowledge of the vessel
the ship is currently a situation
whereby the engine could stop running as
the crew do not know how to transfer
fuel to them this morning the vessel
almost run out of water i don't want to
read too much i don't want to give the
identity identity of the person or the
ship away
how absurd is it that piano thought that
you're going to authorize these ships in
10 days and how can you authorize these
ships fit when this is information we're
getting from crew on board the ships
difficult for me to respond when i don't
know the ship if that information was
shared with the mca and we knew what
that ship would be we could obviously
bring forward the inspection mr johnson
yep
same thing if if we have the information
we can bring it forward you know we will
we will apply uh
as katie said the
port state control inspections
absolutely rigorously and
you know if we've got safety concerns
and our surveyors are good at what they
do we've got safety concerns those ships
will not sail all right
another message i received um
the mca will verify the vessel is safe
to sail this is from a person on board
the ship the mca will verify the vessel
is safe to sell when the ship's master
and officers indicate that they are
ready and we expect a support state
inspection as the vessels are flagged in
the bahamas um as the ship
officers were expected the vessels will
pass initial inspection as the majority
of the officers
are unfamiliar with the ship
how is this being managed how many
communications are we having on board
with people on the ship to give you the
confidence
that you can let the ships go
so our surveyors would have
conversations on board during the
inspection that's a key part of part of
what they do katy do you want you want
to illustrate the sort of conversations
that take place
it's uh it's difficult for us to
pre-judge until we get on board of those
vessels
but our absolute priority is when we get
on board of those vessels is doing to
ensure
that the seafarers on board
are familiarized qualified and are clear
about their responsibilities
so until we get on board it's difficult
for us to pre-judge but you have my
absolute assurance that we will go in
absolute detail to ensure that those
crew on board are familiarized qualified
trained and that we are satisfied that
they can operate those ships safely and
those vessels will not leave until we
are satisfied that they are safe to
operate to be clear we are not working
through a timetable on this i work into
a time thing but they want to be done in
10 days
so do you think it's gonna be 10 days or
20 days or three months i don't i don't
have a view we we will do our job on the
the port state port state inspections
will do it will do it well
a maritime coast guard agency has a
really stellar reputation and what piano
ferris has done has just undermined the
reputation of the mca there were three
flag states involved overseas why was
there not better communication with the
mca with yourselves for them to give new
notice that they had been given notice
so you could start communicating with
piano ferries
we
we don't
we've spoken to the flag states and they
were not informed until the 17th
one more time for the record mr johnson
we we've been in communication with the
flag states and they were not informed
until the 17th that's thursday last week
flag states themselves that is um
cyprus
bahamas
that's correct that's that's what
they've told us and the action of piano
ferries i would argue has undermined all
the work that
the sector
governments
and even myself when i was in the
department um all the work we're doing
towards maritime 2050
taking a decision how we manage take
care of seafarers in the uk and our
relationship with companies such as
piano ferris what do you suggest mr
johnson i i think what we need to do is
make sure that the maritime coast guard
agency
continues to operate with the
absolute professionalism that it's that
it's known for and our commitment is to
do that and you take care of the
flagging as well don't you
wouldn't take care of flagging as well
within yeah and doesn't this undermine
flagging as well so we've got two more
passenger ferry companies
flagged with fantastic
grade a seafarers their business model
now they'll feel is is being being
challenged
of course we love to have as many ships
on the uk flag as we this doesn't help
well frozen's done it doesn't help that
does it whatsoever i can't
i'd love to have more ships on the uk
flag and i just asked when was the last
time you spoke to a senior
representative of piano ferries and the
last time you spoke to a senior
representative at dp world
i haven't had any communications with dp
world i spoke to the chief executive of
piano ferries on
monday morning to uh to make sure that
we had proper lines of communication and
clarity on what was happening when so
there was a teams call i had
with him with one of his colleagues and
me with one of my colleagues on monday
morning can i just for the record ask
when was the last time you were in a
room with a minister providing evidence
support or guidance over this issue
you know can i do it with a team's call
rather than a room can we do a virtual
room uh that was yesterday
first time sorry i thought you said the
last time that was the last time was
yesterday when was the first time the
first time on this particular issue
personally uh uh
let me think back um
i'm really not sure i think the the bulk
of the communication has been
the one that katie had thank you i've
got two supplementaries but i'm also
very conscious that mr beale i don't
want you to feel like you've missed a
morning in the sun
the secretary of state has written to
the insolvency service asking you to
look at the notification requirements
and the potential for penalty uh
penalties to be applied to piano ferries
we heard in the first panel
that if piano ferries had not notified
the flag nations with appropriate notice
so cyprus bahamas bermuda that that is a
breach of uk notification law do you
agree with that
i think you know
my team are working through
all of the facts on this case looking at
the law
uh and you know we will very quickly i
think arrive at a determination as to
whether you know there have been
breaches and what action could be taken
as a result when will you come to that
conclusion well the secretary of state
has asked for a response from us by the
8th of april so we're working very hard
you'll have heard this morning
by then and the officers why does it
take so long to review we had a lawyer
saying it was illegal we had several
lawyers saying it was illegal how long
do you need
the their inquiry is ongoing um there
are inquiries with the uh
foreign jurisdictions that colleagues in
the department for transport are
pursuing
we need to gather all that information
in we need to please don't you you've
been told that there were notified on
the 17th of march uh and that is
inappropriate there's a breach of the of
the law we that is that is established
it's what you now do with that sorry
chair with the interpretation of that
breach of the law
i mean if we can come back to the
secretary state quicker we absolutely
will i think you probably should um and
just on the question of penalties there
was some confusion in the first panel
about how you would calculate a penalty
if this overseas notification was done
inaccurately what's your view on that
uh
i think i think that's again it's it's
really unclear i mean we heard this
morning the complexities of the sort of
different applicable laws that might be
appropriate in in the case where there's
multiple jurisdictions on the face of it
my understanding is that
the penalty for failure to notify
would sit with the jurisdiction where
that requirement to notify would exist
we need to look at that very carefully
very interesting um uh
contributions from the speakers this
morning which we will we will absolutely
look at very carefully as well okay we
have to move on but i suggest you really
do you need to move quicker than getting
an answer by the 8th of april um chris
lowder please
thank you mr chairman um brian and katie
i just want to say that from what i've
heard from you today
and as someone who's worked in the
transport sector for my entire career
before coming to parliament
i'm quite concerned about the
effectiveness of the safety regulator
from what i've heard from you today
um i'd appreciate it very much if you
would share with us
the paperwork that was signed off for
the pride of hold to sale and i think um
certainly my colleague
mr morris and i would be quite keen to
understand a little bit more details and
later point when you do further
inspections to understand the extent to
which
we have confidence in that thank you
thank you thank you merriman i just want
to come back so
the issues that's been raised is the
concept of moving from one week on one
week off to two weeks do you have a view
given you know the rostering has got to
be within safety do you have a view on
whether that is normal safe
concerns
the key thing here is the hours of rest
and ensuring that the crew so you could
have crew on board for up to six months
that's permissible the key thing is
ensuring that those crew have their
hours of rest that are required by law
and when we go on board the vessels we
inspect those hours of rest to ensure
and they've got to be recorded um so the
key thing is making sure that the crew
are rested and able to perform their
their jobs
right do not look at it and say actually
from a safety good practice perspective
these shift patterns are a
right good industry standard this isn't
it's a deviation
it's not for me to
tell ship operators what their shift
patterns should be the key thing is that
they get their hours of rest i think it
should be actually for you to tell them
what the shift what their pattern should
be because you're responsible for safety
and actually if you believe that's not
safe then i think you should sorry brian
no it's okay so again this is a slightly
complicated regime that we operate
within so the the primary
responsibilities around this are with
let's say that sorry the ship was
flagged with cyprus for example prime
responsibilities you move the mic back
over so we're kind of honey the prime
responsibilities would lie with uh
cyprus and the ship operator to get that
right what we do then is is apply
uh
international regulation and then the
appropriate uk local uk regulations so
that's that's uh if the cypriots say
it's safe test is it rather uk and if
we're uncomfortable with that we can
obviously
we can write to the the cyprus uh flag
regime but that's that's a slightly
complicated um
regulatory framework that we operate in
and i'm coming to the conclusion i'm
interested in your powers whether
actually given
given what i remember in terms of herald
of free enterprise that i'm slightly
concerned that we're actually relying on
what the cypriot standards of safety are
are asked on the straits of dover
listen
because you've just said actually that's
a cypriot
but it's it's but it's also governed by
a set of international uh
regulation and uh safety engineering
yeah international i'm talking our own
uk high standards here
which seems to be a bit unless other
members can completely understand it and
i'm i'm missing the point we're not
entirely clear here whether cyprus
governs uk governs or whether you've
actually got the best of both
highest standards of both so perhaps
answer that right so the cyprus flag
they're responsible for setting the
manning levels on board the safe manning
levels on board
what we would expect from report state
control is the working hours to make
sure that they're working the necessary
and they're getting their rest hours in
a certain set period i don't have to
hand the exact specifics of what the
working regulations but i can write you
to verify that yeah can you write to us
and just set out this hierarchy and
which which applies and then the last
point i want to ask is have you dealt
with anything on the scale of this
before in terms of seeing crews change
such large numbers
never in my career and then and you have
the sort of holistic powers rather than
just looking at the individuals i mean
why wouldn't you
turn around and say actually i'm looking
at this from an entire practice it
cannot be
safe
and certainly in terms of days to be
able to completely change your crew and
bring brand new crew on so rather than
even looking at the individual parts can
you look at this holistically and say
this can't be safe we've got to operate
within the powers of that port state
control regime which are all set out
we're part of the paris memorandum of
understanding a group of countries that
do port state inspections and our powers
are really set out within that so we're
dissatisfied with the safety on a ship
we can detain it but it's on a ship by
ship uh basis and we have to inspect it
in order to use to use that power we we
haven't got those uh those holistic uh
powers that you might you might actually
look at on a ship by ship basis to say
this practice is so unheard of for us we
can't cope with this as an agency we're
really concerned about safety so
therefore we'd have to base it on the
inspections that we do when we get on
board the ships and on the results of
those inspections
i've got two final supplementaries but
i'm going to have to limit you to one
minute question one minute answer please
gavin newlands thanks just a point of
clarification you mentioned
uh wrestles and obviously working 10
regulations etc don't really apply here
but as i recall from my previous career
you've got different rest hours you've
got your daily rest hours and you've got
weekly and perhaps monthly rest hours
depending on the job
if you sit as long as you get a 12 hour
rest per day that's fine or is it
because i'm because the way you answer
the question it sounds if they could
work for six weeks only six weeks off as
long as you get the 12 hours recipe per
day so could you clarify that sorry uh
my apologies mr newlands no we don't
just look at the daily rest we look at
the weekly and the monthly hours as well
what would you be what's your minimum
requirement on that
i haven't got those details to
graeme uh thanks very much
um in the statement on the um hudson
pakistan on the 17th of march the
shipping minister laid grit stole by
your intervention was having heard your
explanation about the restrictions that
apply in respect of the the the relevant
flag i'm less than convinced
you mentioned you'd had a number of
meetings with ministers including
yesterday some by zooming and and some
in person how frequently have you met
with the trade unions with nautilus
international and the rmt they're the
experienced
safe fares and officers who know what
safety systems are if i might just say i
had a terrible experience many years ago
going from strand alone in a very stormy
sea and i was so grateful to have
experienced seafarers who were able to
anchor the hgvs that were moving in that
stormy sea and could have jeopardized
the safety of the ship
wouldn't it be reasonable to have
discussions with the existing crews and
their representatives i'd say in answer
to the general question uh
we and the rmt in nautilus are in fairly
regular contact but not we haven't been
on
this particular issue they have written
to us and we have responded to the
concerns that they put in put in writing
to us and we we got another letter
yesterday which we will respond to uh
first thing tomorrow
um
but we haven't had face-to-face dialogue
over this particular issue we have we
have more broadly got very good
communications i think between ourselves
and the trade unions given the flat
brian both you and katie have said this
is unprecedented you know the scale of
the sackings and the impact it's having
in this particular sector in this
operator
wouldn't it be pruned to have
face-to-face meetings
with people who are actually familiar
with safe working practices
i think you know we're very ready to be
to have
dialogue with rmt and with nautilus
uh in
taking them through what our findings
are
on the inspections uh when we do the
inspections i think i think though the
you know one of the challenges here is
as
we were outlining earlier is is our
powers are actually quite they're
they're quite
they're quite tightly defined
so there's actually quite limited room
for maneuver here we've we've got to do
our job and we've got to do our job very
very well and very professionally
but there's quite limited flexibility
around that because of the framework
that we operate within i understand that
but it's
it's a it's a critical issue safety but
sorry
thank you thank you to the three of you
for your contributions this morning
we're grateful we're now moving on to
our fourth panel uh where we're
welcoming on the screen jasper
christensen who's the chief
commercial operations officer at
maritime services for dp world
and in the room we'll be welcoming peter
hebelthwaith who is the chief executive
of piano fairies we'll just let
people join the screen and the room
all right peter just the one next your
name's on that one thank you i apologize
and there's some fresh water there for
you as well
okay we'll get going uh mr hepworth wait
um when i was reading your biography it
seemed pretty light
uh on your experience as a chief
executive officer are you in this mess
because you don't know what you're doing
or are you just a shameless criminal
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to come and answer questions um
and actually before i answer that
question can i start please with an
apology
um actually an apology
to
um
the seafarers that were affected
on thursday last week
an apology
to their families
an apology to the
2200 of our employees
who have had to face very difficult
questions over the last week or so
and
you may see this as a late apology and i
just want to reassure you
that the reason that um
you're hearing this i guess for the
first time today is because i've spent
the last week in the business talking to
our people
one to one
why didn't you talk to them in advance
in a consultation with them with faith
why apologize after you've sacked them
all
so
the context of this incredibly difficult
decision
is that piano has lost
an unsustainable amount of money
and
the reality is and this is the backdrop
that i would ask you please to bear in
mind is that we would have had to close
the business
if we hadn't i'm sorry to interrupt i
have lots of businesses come to my
committee and tell me that but they all
consult before they make their staff
redundant you didn't why not
so
we thought long and hard about the
routes to this and we did consider every
single option available to us and we
concluded that every single option
available to us
would result in the closure of pno
and ultimately and i haven't uh had a
chance and it would be great to talk to
you about what this actual new accruing
model looks like
but it is of such a it is a
fundamentally different operating model
and no union could accept
um did you ask them our proposal did you
ask the trade unions
no okay in your letter to the secretary
of state you said that you notified the
relevant um competent authorities in
cyprus the bahamas and bermuda on the
17th of march is that correct yes
we heard earlier that was in breach of
your notification requirements to notify
cyprus within 45 days of the first
dismissal and the bahamas and bermuda
within 30 days do you recognize that
not being a lawyer
well i presume you have access to
lawyers of course and and we we
uh are clear that we have not breached
that law who did you write to in cyprus
i will have to get back to you who did
you write to in the bahamas
i'll have to get back who did you write
to in bermuda let me respond did you
sign off these letters
no
can you provide this committee with
copies of them yes thank you what's your
salary mr hepathway my salary is 300
basic salary of 325 000 pounds you have
access to a performance related bonus i
have access to two performance-related
bonus um a short-term incentive planned
a long-term center plan you've increased
or decreased the value of p ferries by
your actions
i think the pno
was otherwise going to close
and didn't have a future and so if your
employers are might i suggest mad enough
to offer you a performance related bonus
will you accept it or reject it
at least i can't tell you how far that
is from my point of principle will you
accept it or reject it
i don't know the answer to that if we
managed to save the company there's a
decision for you if i'm offering you a
performance related bonus and you've
just sacked 800 people will you as a
point of principal say i'm not going to
take that
i don't know the answer to that i'm not
i'm not i've got to be honest i'm not
focused on that i'm focused on saving
the business and getting the 800
seafarers new jobs right and you
recognize that asking your employees to
sign a settlement agreement means that
they are withdrawing their rights for
further legal action against pno
yes i do and we are and we are making
extremely generous payments as a result
of that 36 and a half million pounds we
think the largest maritime um
settlement
arrangement in history
uh there will be people receiving
upwards of 170 000 pounds but actually
probably
i don't know
very few
there will be about 40 who will receive
um
more than 100 000 but most importantly
actually
is at the other end of that scale where
we have capped the minimum so if
somebody started work with us
in the last month or so actually we've
said that we will pay a minimum of 15
000 pounds so we've uncapped the top and
we've absolutely said as a minimum we
will pay 15 000 pounds we recognize we
did a very very difficult thing we
recognize money isn't everything but we
do want to compensate people fully and i
absolutely want to be focused on getting
them all new jobs thank you mr
christensen on the screen please from dp
world the owner of piano ferries are you
going to sack mr hepathwaite for gross
misconduct
i couldn't imagine that we would do that
no and did you sign off on these
proposals
so um dp world has been informed on a
continuous basis on
the
situation in piano paris
obviously as the
shareholder did you sign up we've also
been and we have we've also been
informed of the evaluation that pfl
paris have had in terms of different
routes to making this business viable
and sustainable
and eventually also being informed
and supporting the decision that was
then eventually taken
thank you and mr hepathwaite just said
uh mr christensen that p a ferries is
about to presumably go immediately bust
unless you sacked 800 members of your
staff do you agree with that assessment
so the business piano ferris
has definitely lost a lot of money over
the last few years
no business can sustain that forever
the business
was not viable in that
in the situation or in under those
conditions
so a number of things have been
evaluated and eventually this model was
then chosen as
the only route
available
as an alternative to um ending up in
limitation or
it's very strange mr christensen because
lots of other businesses in trouble
follow perfectly legal routes but um you
seem to be having no regrets about the
decisions taken by your business the
last question from me was i've got you
mr
mr german with all your respect uh
having no regrets you have not heard me
saying that we have no regrets we
actually would you like to express also
also as dp world we acknowledge the pain
that this has caused to a lot of people
employees seafarers their families etc
so you're not heard me saying that we do
not acknowledge that well i'm sure the
families are grateful for your regrets
after sucking them mr christians in my
last question for you is i understand
that dp world owes 146 million pounds to
the merchant navy ratings pension fund
when are you going to pay that
i don't know if the 146 is the right
number uh i have no knowledge of that
i understand it is and i also understand
that you know
147 million pounds sponsoring a golf
tournament so it should be affordable
for you shouldn't it
may i add the point please so the uh
liability for the pension fund as i
understand is a pno liability and we
have um an agreement and we will all of
those agreements to make those
repayments
thank you and dp world will be giving
you the money to do that presumably
given you don't have any well
sadly
the reality is this was a very difficult
step that we had to take to make the
company viable and profitable at which
point we will be able to honor our own
commitments
very good andy mcdonald uh thank you
chair uh mr christensen you talk about
um this being painful and difficult uh
your company paid out 376 million uh
dollars in dividends to shareholders the
last two years alone couldn't you use
some of that money to treat the
workforce at piano with some decency and
dignity don't you think that was your
duty
so dp world has taken absolutely zero
dividends out of piano ferry for the
last many years
so we have we on the country we have
kept on
supporting the business
over and over again
supporting the
existence of that business for a number
of years with hundreds of millions of
pounds okay without regard to the
welfare of the of the workforce um uh mr
hepathwick uh did piano have a duty to
consult the unions in good time over the
redundancies pursuant to section 188 of
the uh trade union act of 1992.
there's absolutely no doubt that we were
required to consult with the unions we
chose not to do that because we believe
she chose to break the law because we
chose not to consult and we will come
and we are and will compensate everybody
in full for that i recognize that this
is a really you get in your car and
drive on the motorway you see the 70
mile an hour sign do you sound that
that's not going to apply to me i'm
going to do 90 because i think it's
important that i do that is that how you
go about your life no no it isn't did
the collective agreements in place
between piano and rnt and nautilus
provide for negotiation over such
matters as redundancies
all right could you rephrase the
question
you had collective agreements correct
with rmt and pia
and nautilus that provides for
negotiation over such matters of
redundancies you've done it before why
didn't you do it what was the moral
justification for you not doing that
okay so this is these are very extreme
circumstances let me can i in order to
answer that question fully can i explain
the difference between the operational
uh model that we previously had and the
one that we are moving to so you
understand how fundamental a change it
is and that helps me explain why we had
to take the route we had to take would
you allow me sorry is this is the chairs
already pointed out there's many
companies that have difficulties they
obey the law and they consult with their
but their members through their trade
unions you haven't done that we've moved
from one operating model to another
you haven't you haven't escaped the law
of this country you've still got to do
it within the legal framework you can't
just decide that you're going to absent
yourself from the legal system united
kingdom so it is it was our assessment
that the change was of such a magnitude
that no union could possibly accept our
proposal oh you're right about that
i've never heard such farcical answers
to a series of questions okay can i move
on chair um in selecting uk employees
most of whom will be uk nationals or
residents or residents when you selected
them for dismissal
pno was evidently discriminated
against them on grounds of nationality
what was the legal justification for
doing this
to be clear actually these weren't
exclusively uk nationals
they were largely uk nationals but this
is this was a group of international
employees
so what are the new rates of pay to be
offered to the new crews how much are
you paying them so the two models the
two models are very different so to
answer that question is a bit more
complicated if you can allow me the time
the previous operating model required us
to have four crews for every ship on
dover cali
the new operating model
um
requires us to have two ship two crews
and pay people when they work so they're
assessed in slightly different ways the
answer to your question is that the
average jersey seafarer was in was paid
36 000 pounds and will receive 46 and a
half thousand pounds so a year and a
third in compensation
so that's part of the answer to the
question the second part of the question
is what are the hourly rates of pay
for the new model so the average hourly
rate to pay is 5 pounds 50.
on top of that there is a pension
contribution
there is food and accommodation
and then
so can i make a couple of points please
so on the routes that are international
routes that are governed by itf
standards we are paying above itf
minimum wages and on
our domestic route which i think was
referenced earlier lanca ryan where we
are governed by national minimum wage of
course we are paying national minimum
wage and and so uh so the seafarers
aboard the vessels that are leaving
dover the replacement crew
they're going to be paying on average
paid at the rate of 5 pounds and 50
pence per hour yes that's below the
national minimum wage of this country
how do you how do you reconcile that
where we are governed by national
minimum wage we will absolutely pay
national minimum wage this is an
international seafaring model that is
consistent with uh models throughout the
globe and our competitors did you live
on it mister hepatitis 50 now could you
could you sustain your lifestyle five
pounds fifty an hour
no you couldn't could you why do you
expect people who've got such
responsible jobs to be able to do that
how do you expect them to be able to
feed their families and pay their bills
at five pounds fifty an hour there's a
couple of very very important points
here one yes it's one that's called gas
one scores electric those are the
important points they can't pay their
bills one couple of important points
please um these uh the seafarers who are
joining us are international
professional seafarers with all the
international certification these are
these are experienced seafarers
i've got to move on can i can i ask mr
christensen because mr christensen on
your website dp world you say the dp
world respects and supports the human
rights of our employees you're going to
say amongst other things in relation to
collective bargaining dp world respects
the laws and labor practices for each
country and will not hinder the
development of means for independent and
free association
how would you square that with the
experience of your company piano
sorry your the line was breaking up one
more time please the latter part of the
question well you you'll be familiar
with your own human rights statement uh
which adheres to the universal
declaration on human rights the ilo
declaration on fundamental principles
and rights at work the guiding
principles on business and human rights
and yet you've completely trashed them
in this they're not worth are you going
to take this down off your website
because it's an insult
so i do not
believe that it's an insult and i do not
believe that any of what we have done uh
to ask the 800 people
is in conflict in conflict with any of
that of course it's a direct conflict i
you know we hear some ridiculous things
but for you to say that those those
principles still obtain when people have
been summarily dismissed without no
notice whatsoever and replaced by people
on 5.50 an hour is an outrage there's
some nda's here mr hepleth are you going
to rescind those because quite frankly
the members of this committee think this
is absolutely thuggery
and criminality you're behaving like
gangsters to blackmail people into this
situation will you withdraw those ndas
and let people have the freedoms that we
all enjoy
i assume you're talking to about the
confidentiality clause that's in the
severance agreements
agreements yes it's a standard
confidentiality clause and actually it's
there to protect both sides
oh god um okay i i'm just getting into
the end of this um let me just ask one
one more um you and why did you employ
private uh private security firm to
remove seafarers uh from your vessel we
were you pleased with what you saw on
our televisions on social media of
people with handcuffs marching up the
gang plants onto these vessels why did
you do that
i i don't think you have seen pictures
of people in handcuffs because actually
it was very clear we did employ a
security firm of professionals and
actually what i and the reason for that
was to keep our people and the ships
safe and the reality is coming out of
this is that we have didn't get a single
incident throughout the day we kept
everybody safe everybody's secure mr
hepburn people were terrified they were
going about their work in the ordinary
way to see people invade the ships and
start
ordering them about telling that they
had to pack their bags and go is that a
humane way to treat loyal employees
who've given you such incredible service
is that decent
the security team were there to keep the
ships and most importantly the people
say for the time that was genuinely a
stressful time for them it was our
assessment
that that was because you made it
stressful you were the author of the
stress
there's no doubt that when people hear
that they are losing their job it is
extremely stressful we wanted to keep
the ships and most importantly our
people safe thank you thank you kevin
newlands please
thank you much chair i think just to
come back on this can you perhaps
clarify for the committee and to
everyone watching on to
um the penal workers
what employment law provisions have you
breached
so we have not consulted
and for that we are fully compensating
people for that in full upfront
how much how much is the business going
to save
each year by sacking the crew similarly
and
employing agency staff so this entirely
different model is about half the price
of the previous model about half the
price yeah
and you said
the average
um wage of the of the seafarers in the
new model what's the lowest minimum
lowest early rate in the new model 515
the lowest yeah
you said an answer to mr mcdonald the
average was five pounds 50 is everyone
from the bottom fifteen
five fifteen
five fifteen the average range is from
550 to about six pounds depending on
exchange rate but i gave you the low end
of that
five pounds fifteen
and and do you think that's
a fair wage do you think that
international maritime laws in terms of
wages are are fair and sustainable or as
many people now now see it as modern day
slavery which would you say to that so
the rates that we're paying are in line
or above itf minimum standards and it is
it is the it is the uh operating model
that the vast majority of operators
across the globe work to so this is the
competitive standard
i appreciate that but do you think the
itf standards are fair and reasonable is
that something that the world perhaps in
light of this that your action are going
to have to look at and address
i think that their negotiated
rates of pay and therefore um you know
those have been successfully negotiated
on both parts
i'm not sure how successful it was in
the workers partner to be perfectly
honest
um
over the last year
have pno or ndp world broached with any
government minister or official uh that
you may be changing practice at any
point not an official notification of
what you what you did last thursday but
any hint or indication as to what you
might be doing or looking at i can share
my understanding
but i wasn't at the meeting
so
i believe that on the 22nd of november
the secretary of state for transport was
visiting dubai and at expo he met with
some of the dp world exec team and that
as as part of a broader ranging
discussion which included ongoing
investment in the british economy the
subject of piano ferries was brought up
and that we would be needing to make
some changes to our business this year
beyond that i can't confirm all i can
say is that at that point in our
planning we hadn't finalized our plans
so i doubt any conversation went further
than that but i don't know
i appreciate that the final plans hadn't
been made but um
but that's quite an important point
you've just raised could you perhaps
look into that and provide the committee
with more detail on that meeting because
the fact that the government perhaps
were warned that some things are fit
months in advance um is quite an
interesting point
the committee might want to know can i
turn my attention to um to mr
christensen um
is this
has any other dp world company ever
undertaken such an action is this
standard practice for dp world is this a
first
i don't know to be quite honest
in the period of time of time that i
have been occupied with dp world
i do not think that there has been
anything
similar to this but we've also not had a
situation
in the company or in the businesses that
is owned by dp world that is similar to
the one that piano ferris has been
finding itself in
just for clarity could you perhaps again
write to the committee just to confirm
that indeed this is the first time a dp
world company has has undertaken this
sort of action
and for deputy impact on dp world are
you concerned
um what this might mean for dp world and
its relationship with the uk government
uh moving forward and as we understand
it you have an agreement in place with
the government with regards to free
ports
and do you think this will have an
impact on that agreement
so i am responsible for the maritime
activities in dp world
and cannot speak for
what that means to other parts of the
business but i can assure you as we have
done both mr hipperswath and me in this
session that we've taken
a lot of consideration to the decision
that was taken here piano various board
have been
coming to dp world consulting with us on
this we've been informed we have made
everything that we could to make sure
that that all proper care was taken we
have taken everything that we can do to
make sure that the people affected are
being looked after
so yeah of course we have taken into
consideration that that this decision
could have some kind of impact um
beyond uh piano various
but still we have had
given or we have given a piano various
the support for that decision under the
prevailing circumstances did you did you
essentially force piano to take this
decision or was it just a broader they
must save x million
sorry one more time
did the dp world force piano to take
this decision
so piano ferris is um business in his
own good right and the piano various
board will have to take the business
decisions for piano ferries that it has
to take
so
dp world is interested and and obviously
focused on making sure that our
businesses are viable whether they are
in the one corner of the world or the
other
but at the end of the day the
operational decisions in piano various
is piano fairies to decide upon
okay thanks and back to mr
uh he will wait did you anticipate such
a reaction
could i also just confirm mr
christensen's point this was a piano
ferry's board decision we of course
required funding and support to do it
but ultimately this was a pno ferry's
decision this was not forced on us or
even suggested to us idp world
but um sorry your question was
um
what was my question again
were you expecting this reaction yes oh
sorry i do apologize
the reaction to this has been extremely
strong there's no question about that
and i
i do regret that and i recognize it i
really really do recognize it but there
was no piano without the changes that we
needed to make so
we anticipated this would be very
difficult very controversial and
lastly for me for a handbag
you're not concerned that these actions
will actually bring about the end of
puno rather than save it
i think we've got a tough job to do now
to rebuild the business but i think a
piano with a future and a piano that is
able to be competitive pay its own bills
and offer the customer service that is
required
has a much better chance
thank you i'm i i'm afraid i have
indications for questions from literally
every member of the community so
apart from you so i'm going to call you
all but please just keep your questions
and answers tight and keep it moving
please nazareth ghani okay mr evil wait
is it accurate that you said that the
minister was informed on the 27th of
november 22nd 22nd of november my
understanding which one which minister
secretary sorry the secretary of state
for transport if i misspoke i apologize
you have a minute of that conversation i
don't know
what a mess
what a mess so piano fairies have been
operating since 1844 and then
one zoom meeting you trash it all trash
it all 800 people now on the dole
and um you're now trying to clean this
up having ruined the reputation of piano
fairies and undermined
everything we're trying to do in the
sector even encouraging people to come
forward and become seafarers
and you're saying that you've got a
number of regrets i've just seen been
sent a picture of pride of kent where i
believe
crew that you've dumped on the dole all
of their bits and pieces are in bin bags
why have you done that why don't you fix
that right now why don't you fix that
right now make sure that the people that
you fight have some dignity and get hold
of the items that they've left behind
can you fix that right here right now so
actually i've already taken steps to see
what has happened there and i have been
assured so we will find out the
specifics of that photograph but i have
been assured that
the team are taking personal
responsibility for returning people's
belongings to them take them out the bin
bags
and give them back to the people they
belong to give them some dignity
so can i just the
bags that people were given was on the
day so they could have something to
carry off the possessions that they
could carry the
possessions they're otherwise taking
we're returning to them and we're
employing companies to do that and box
them up and return them you would heard
from the early session the anxiety that
we have that the mca will be able to
credibly allow the ships to sail and
you've come forward to say you've got a
number of regrets and we would have
hoped that maybe you're going to be
treating a new crew a little bit better
i've had i've had messages over the
weekend from people on board and this
doesn't give me any confidence you're
going to treat the new crew any better
um
so the messages say the replacement
officers were not informed they were
replacing crew being made redundant and
we were told that a new company is being
set up and it could possibly be from
glasgow
no representatives from pno were present
when they were on board the ships to
brief the new offices and we've had no
direction from piano as to next steps to
take
you must understand the fundamentals
of managing a passenger ferry service
surely you've been told and briefed this
gives me no confidence that the new crew
have confidence in in the leadership or
even your leadership or whether they
think
the the ferries are competent to sail
what's going on it just seems to get
worse every day
so a couple of things um we
did employ a professional security firm
to talk to people we had to talk to them
all at the same time
you mentioned a zoom call so the nature
of this crewing model is that at any one
time half of our
seafarers were on board and the other
half
were at home spread throughout europe
and so
we wanted to inform everybody at the
same time so people on board where at
all possible we spoke to them in person
people who were not and who are at home
and spread throughout europe we had no
option but to invite them to a teams
meeting that was uh there was a live
meeting yes it was scripted but it
wasn't pre-recorded i think that's
important and then we followed that up
with one-to-one phone calls where we
could get hold of them and of course we
followed up in writing replacement
offices yes why have they not been given
one-to-one meetings where have they not
been spoken to by piano leadership piano
ferris leadership we've we've been on
board in fact we've had some of our
fleet management team and our and our
and our and our ship's support services
have actually been living on board the
ships to help with the familiarization
and the training
we i've been on board i've spoken to the
new crew and the new officers we've had
51 officers ask for the paperwork to
join the crewing management company
and come back and help rebuild the
business
can i ask why you didn't come forward to
the department to ask for more advice or
guidance to try and get you out of the
situation you felt that you were in so
we
uh we think we felt it's important that
we were able to have a viable ongoing
business and we needed to move to a
competitive operating model that is
recognized throughout the world and our
competitors also use
it was a very uh it was a very difficult
very difficult step we had to take
and all of my regrets around it are
around the impact it's had on the
individuals but i do recognize it as a
step we had to take
we didn't talk to
really very many people at all because
of the nature of we knew it was going to
be controversial and it needed to be
confidential because without that
confidentiality we simply wouldn't have
been able to implement this incredibly
difficult decision
you change anything knowing what you
know now what you did last thursday
that's a really really difficult
question
the business would close the business
was not viable this is the only way for
us to save this business and we have
moved to a model that is internationally
recognized and widely used across the
globe and by our competitors
i
um
i would make this decision again i'm
afraid
well um just one quick clarification
before i go on to another member um you
said mr hebel vote to miss ghani that
you had a discussion with the transport
secretary on the 22nd of november i
didn't uh have a i didn't i wasn't part
of that discussion but i believe that um
that a conversation was had in dubai at
expo on the 22nd of november with who
with the state
electricity
who was the secretary having a
conversation with it wasn't you who was
it transport
sorry
the transport secretary had a discussion
with somebody in dubai yes
who
i uh some some senior executives at dp
world i don't know if you who i wasn't
there mr christensen who had that
conversation with the transport
secretary in dubai
i don't know either
i was also not participating in the
presumably you can find out for us and
let us know yes and i think i think that
mr newlands asked us to do that thank
you can i can i please reiterate at that
point
our plans were nowhere near finalized so
it is unlikely that that conversation
would have had any real substance to it
i suspect
you didn't participate okay greg morris
please thank you thanks chair um you you
may recall uh mr hamill white previously
all this is a joint committee with the
uh
of transport and buys there was an
invitation
and from transport to to where to come
to our committee we were looking at
corvid support during the pandemic and
there was a change in the chief exec at
the time that wasn't possible but that
was a rising out of the corvette support
the company received
and the i think that the frayed grant as
well it was around about 15 million
pounds
but
it was also because a number of
redundancies had been announced
affecting a number of ports uh
where penal phrase were involved what
was different that you were prepared to
respect uk law and consult with the
recognized trade unions on that occasion
and yet weren't prepared to do it on
this occasion
so it's quite a lot that was different
but it's a good question so um during
the covid uh pandemic during the height
of it we anticipated it would come to an
end in the early part of 2021 and we
anticipated that we would be able to
restructure the business with limited
redundancies and that that was a
reasonable
conversation and we absolutely consulted
with that the curve pandemic has gone on
much longer and we now need to
fundamentally
address the viability of this business
otherwise it closes in 2000 an
additional 2 200 people lose their jobs
and so in this situation we will need to
change our operating model
and on that basis and i know i know the
reaction i got last time but it is true
that we assessed that given the
fundamental nature of change
that no union
could accept it and therefore we chose
not to consult because a consultation
process would have been a sham
and we didn't want to go put anybody
through that and we want and we want and
we are and we are
compensating people in full and up fund
for that decision
do you have a name for this new
operating model the the new operating
model that you're applying with the with
the reduced crewing and so on and the i
mean it's called multiple things people
call it agency crew um i i i talk about
running our crew through a crewing
management company
i've heard it rather referred to as the
skeleton um crew model i think that's i
think it's really dangerous that we that
we i that i'd let that light these are
very very experienced
fully certified professional
international seafarers they just have
some decent wages then i know time yeah
we're on 50 an hour i know i'm not
trying sorry i'm gonna have to move on
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'll just call
you in the end at the end if i've got
time paul howell please
thank you chair
i i i just find it bizarre that um you
know as a business you've chosen to
break the law as a business decision
it's just it's incomprehensible to me um
you know
you know and now we're laughing stock
you know i think whether you'll find
that it's your german ratna moment in
terms of a business you're seen as
contemptible by any right-minded people
as to the way you're running your
business
i really don't understand how you think
that um the government or anybody else
is going to want to engage with piano or
dp world in anything with any faith or
any trust that you're going to do
anything that you say that you're going
to do in future
with with hindsight do you really think
this is a sustainable way to have your
future do you think that this is
is a viable way to run a business
i think we weren't viable before and i
know
that if we hadn't made radical changes
the business would have closed and i
know i keep repeating it and i apologize
for that but genuinely that would not
have been 800 redundancies with
substantial severance packages that
would have been 3 000 people losing
their jobs and the impact on 3 thousand
people throughout
multiple nationalities
uh mr christensen um you know you made
the comment earlier that um
you know it's a
it was a your
part of the business that was involved
in this and that
i've got the impression that the broader
dp world um assessment wasn't fully
considered into this and it was you know
you talk about not have been associated
to the the teams that are involved in
the free ports type agendas
do you not regret that i mean it seems
to me as though what you've done is
you've exposed your entire business to
contempt not just the risk of p if p and
all going down
do you have any cent regret of that from
even just from a pure business strategy
point of view
let me once again stress that this
decision was also not an easy one for
us to
um
you know sign off and support uh
in terms of piano variance of course it
wasn't
um
i think the commitment
and
of ep world to
the uk
uh economy about billions of pounds of
investment in terminals and
free zones etc
you know that that commitment i think is
is second to none i mean we have not
invested more funds anywhere else
outside of dubai than in the uk
and the commitment to you know ferris
and therefore also a british icon
somebody mentioned back to 1847
yeah that the commitment is also a part
of us being very observant too in this
case that
that we have done everything that we
could to make sure that people were
taken care of
and it was also noted a little bit
earlier
that
the
packages that have been offered to the
affected employees
that they are funded
out of dp world and they are and
therefore that has been very important
to us to make sure that we did
everything we could
support support support the people
who were affected by this that is a you
know also a commitment that we do to
make sure
that no
that doesn't make the decision any
easier but at least we have taken very
seriously to try to make the impact as
bearable if i can use that word as
possible
just just to wrap it check and it really
just i think i think it's bizarre that
you think that the right way to do it is
to buy your way out of following uk law
and i think that's just something that
will come back and bite you sorry chad
thank you thank you simon jack please
thank you mr hamborthwaite you've said
in this session that
what you've done to 800 working people
including people in my own constituency
was necessary to save pno
you might have avoided financial
bankruptcy but in the minds of many
customers you are morally bankrupt
what have you done to the brand
so
no question
the brand has taken a hit
there's no question about i don't deny
that and and you know we did something
that was incredibly difficult and we
knew was going to be controversial
but we now have a business
that we can
rebuild
and grow
a competitive
modern business
i am very very sorry to those 800 people
and their families
um but otherwise the whole business
would have closed and we'd lost a
british icon and 3 000 people lost their
jobs and that is the back the icon's
admired though now the icon is mine in
this
this
disgraceful behavior
how will you recover your brand
it's no longer an icon
it's not a british icon anymore it's not
it's not something we're proud of
well
i we have a future now we wouldn't have
we don't have to close the place if
you've got a future do you think the
customers will want to buy tickets from
you knowing what you've done
i really do i think it will take a while
i do think that there is a hit to our
business and i am
again incredibly sorry
but we do have a future we do have a
business that is now competitive that
now can meet the customer needs and can
pay its bills are you hearing from your
booking systems that people are
cancelling tickets uh cancelling their
trips yes
to what extent
uh well we're not actually on sale um
obviously because at the moment we're
not
in the future the future if huge tickets
have already been bought for things and
tricks that people were looking forward
to have they cancelled them as a result
of this some people certainly have and
it's the the reduction in bookings is
different on different routes partly
because uh people buy with a different
um in a different pattern on different
routes so on dover calais we have taken
a particularly large decline but it's
because those bookings tend to cut be
made two weeks ahead on something like
hull europort where people make bookings
three or four months in advance we're
still maintaining strong levels of
booking as we are online can ryan okay
thank you simon chris please thank you
chairman um
mr healthway thank you i have three very
short questions for you
one um
basically sacked employees
and outsourced employment to
agency staff i think that's the correct
assumption
to approximately a third of your
workforce
that is
dominantly also to uk citizens can you
just tell us briefly why you haven't
done that to french citizens or dutch
citizens why it's just uk citizens
the vast vast majority of our crewing
model was employed through jersey we
have i mean
it might be double figures of french
employees and we have very very very few
numbers of dutch employees so this was
about the suck from here that's right
okay okay um
where is your office based
i have an office in dover and i have an
office in hell could you just tell us
why your ships are flagged in cyprus
bahamas and barbados when they sail from
the united kingdom
so this
predates me by some way
but there was a change made and i
believe that the move to cyprus was um
to do with our maintaining our um
commitments to the french tannish tax
that we have
you and very briefly
i'm assuming you risk assess this
enormous change in your business
and i'm assuming you had a safety risk
assessment
could you tell us what
the result of that risk assessment was
and whether or not you actually uh
shared it with the maritime and coast
guard agency
so
one of the reasons for
engaging this security firm was to keep
everybody and our ships but most
importantly everybody's safe and i have
to reassess i have to restate and i
think it's really important point that
with all the rumors out there the
reality and the facts are that we didn't
have a single incident i'll just be
clear with you i'm talking about your
ability your licence to operate this is
what it's about have you risk assess the
enormous change and have the mta signed
off that risk assessment because in my
opinion i cannot understand how you can
continue to operate ships safely in a
way where you completely remove your
workforce and the mca have not signed
that off and i i'm sorry i didn't ask
the early witnesses that question
specifically but i don't think that's
been signed off so let me just confirm a
couple of things for you we engaged with
the mca before we
before the 17th march we engaged with
them first thing on the 16th it could
completely let me finish the assessment
is the question please so okay so
specific specific thing i i i don't know
the answer to that let me find out but
can i just reassure you about really
just finally i'm sorry
i'm just about to finish i apologize
but do you mean to tell this committee
that the chief executive of pino has not
signed off a safety risk assessment for
massive change in in your business is am
i am i right in saying that all of our
team have been on this i haven't seen
the risk assessment i will i will get
that would you
can i i hope the mta listening to this
because this is outrageous
i cannot believe that you can maintain
your position sir i'm so sorry that you
have signed off such enormous change and
you have not directly seen the safety
risk assessment mr chairman i'm going to
hand back to you thank you thank you um
alan brown please
um
black employment law are
it's this is done under uk employment
law could you do that under french law
or under
law of the netherlands in terms of
employment law that's typing mass
sacking
i haven't explored that so i don't know
the answer to that
i'm not a lawyer i'm afraid and at no
point you've taken advantage of
what lapse was in the uk
so this was not a uk the intention here
was not the uk the intention was to move
from one operating model to another um
thank you ben bradshaw sorry
clarification on that you have dutch and
french-based staff yes very treated in
the same way correct
so
but but in fact to be clear they are a
very small proportion of our overall
crewing models why haven't you treated
them in the same way
because this was about uh addressing a
uh uncompetitive and unsustainable
crewing model that we have from um our
jersey-based crew
model doesn't answer
and then there was one final question
from graham
thanks very much
we're looking for a remedy here
and the option that you've gone for the
model that you've gone for must be
hugely expensive
the recruitment costs the specialist
security firm
and suspending operations so there's no
revenue at the cost of redundancy of the
loyal workforce
are there any circumstances perhaps the
threat of one of an unlimited fine that
would cause pain or furries to think
again and reinstate the workforce
as i say the
business was unviable and unsustainable
and would have had to close had we not
made this incredibly difficult decision
and i'm genuinely deeply sorry to those
people affected and their families
the answer is no
the answer is if we went back to the
previous model we would have to close
the business it is not viable
thank you mr hepath at the beginning of
this panel i asked whether
you either didn't know what you were
doing or whether you willfully broke the
law
you said to this committee today that
you willfully broke the law you chose
not to consult even though you know you
should have done
but you decided to pay people off with
compensation in order to break the law
does that not give you concern that
you're in breach of your legal
obligations as a company director and a
company law
so as i say i completely hold our hands
up my hands up our hands up that we
did choose not to consult that's quite
amazing isn't it you're coming to this
parliament and putting your hands up and
saying you willfully chose to break the
law believe it we did not believe that
there was any other way to do this
compensating people in full
okay
i'm afraid we've run out of time but
peter helped wait um and uh just kristen
said thank you for your time we're now
going to change the chair in order to
start the ministerial session i'm told i
therefore need to suspend the session
just for one minute order order
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
order order we now have our final panel
before us it's the uh ministers and
officials can i just quickly ask them to
introduce themselves to start with
minister courts robert courts the
maritime minister minister scully paul
scully uh minister for labour markets in
this regard
lauren
mike warren the labour market director
at bayes
uh john connell deputy director
maritimer